our next speaker has been of this
conference in fact
he he's been doing nyr conferences
since he started his phd in his words
every conference is a reminder that he
needs to graduate graduate
he's also ranked within the top 10
percent of
saber players in the world and
i always like to keep tons of praise on
dan
uh you know i first met him when he was
in my class at columbia
and he's been an integral part of the
landlander team ever since
i can go on and on singing his praises
and normally i'd make him autograph his
book when he's on stage he wrote pandas
for everyone
but of course there's not an autograph
but luckily we are giving out digital
copies and we're going to start doing
the giveaways pretty soon
so with that i am very proud
and excited to introduce dan
all right so hello everyone my name is
daniel
i am a phd student at virginia tech
i am currently doing my dissertation
topic on data science education and
pedagogy
focused on the medical biomedical and
health sciences
you can kind of look at the github repo
for my dissertation which i realized
just now that i forgot to actually link
to all the irb
and analysis urls in there so it's
literally empty right now
currently working with ann brown and at
tech she works
she um does a sort of data science
consulting service through the libraries
and also has a molecular dynamics
simulation lab
through the biochem department last year
i was
one of the interns at our studio and i
worked on
a project called great this which i will
be talking about today
great this is a auto code grader for
learn our interactive documents and i'm
also
the author of this book called pandas
for everyone which is
essentially data analysis but on the
python side so how's quarantine going
for everyone
we are stuck really in conference calls
all the time
uh to the left here is my sister she is
an icu nurse at north shore lij
out in long island new york uh she was
very much
involved with all of the coveted
response in early january
and what i've been doing is i actually
just bought a 3d printer back in march
and started printing a bunch of
ppe things for uh to mail out to folks
um so that's what i've been doing what
also what i've been doing
uh early in the conference like
essentially 95
in the world we all played animal
crossing um
i actually scraped the animal crossing
wiki page and made in our package out of
it so there is now
and i'm crossing our data i play
i started playing a lot of video games
since i've been cooped up at home i've
been home since
the quarantine for spring break and
mainly i've just been playing a bunch of
beat saber
uh i'm a really bad overwatch player and
i just started my first dnd
campaign uh with a couple of friends so
that's what i've been doing
uh since we've been talking about dogs i
updated my slides
i went for a hike a couple weeks ago
with my dog hobbs and so
here's some pictures of a dog um so the
arts
studio internship um i worked on a
project called great this
uh with barrett shillerke and garrett
grolimund
and one of the things i learned was that
i am a user of r not a developer of r
and you can i wrote a bunch of posts
about my experience last year
uh what was really nice about our studio
was i worked with the
education team and shiny team and so
pretty much every day with the shiny
team we had a
um an agile like
15-minute meeting and with the education
team we essentially met
uh once a week which was really nice and
you can imagine
that when you work for our studio
everyone's dream is wait like they have
a slack channel let's
find out what all the slack channels are
and like join them all
and so that's what i did like my my
first couple weeks there was
joining all the slack channels um and
there was one called
a shiny book which i thought was super
exciting and i joined it and
my only interaction with hadley at the
time uh was this
and at our stereo count this year i sort
of made up for it
uh if you haven't seen pictures i
commissioned
a uh a bunch of bow ties to give out to
the interns and hadley and he actually
wore it so
i like to think that i sort of redeemed
myself there uh as an intern
uh so for the learn our interactive
inter uh tutorials
it is a system that allows you to put in
narrative figures illustrations
everything that we all know about our
markdown files but also
now have the ability to add in code
exercises
which are really like our code chunks
that you can execute and
change and type and run it also allows
for quiz questions
uh you can insert videos and interactive
training components so
it's really a system to sort of improve
learning are
and so how do you make a learner
tutorial uh just like everything else in
our markdown
you edit the yaml header so we have a
learner tutorial as the output
and everything because of all of the our
components that need to be run it is
really a
glorified shiny application so there's a
runtime called shiny pre-rendered
and all we need to do is put in
exercise equals to true and we now
create and
learn our uh block what does that look
like so this
up here is the code that we just typed
and down here is the output of something
that of what a learner output looks like
you have a block where you can type in
code and you have a button to run and
the output gets executed on the bottom
so in education um so what other cool
thing that was being developed there is
a library called sortable
um that lets you sort things this is a
almost like a shiny widget
and you can sort things in different
orders and you can see how the result
the resulting vector comes back
depending on the order that you sort
things
so from the education perspective you
can use something like that to create
parsons problems
which allows you to create questions
to teach new learners by reducing the
cognitive load by
reducing the actual code that they need
to type like all of the fluff
and just having them to put the code in
the right order so they're not
so now they're focused on what the
context concepts are instead of exactly
how to write the syntax
and so it looks something like this if
you want like a d plier example
sort of allows you to put things in a
specific order
and then you can essentially use this as
a way to grade and mark
code so what about grading the actual
questions so we can
create the questions but what about
feedback uh students need some way to
know
that like their answer was right or
wrong
so the easiest way to doing that is just
looking at the result
so this just checks to see if the output
of some expression is equal to the
solution so
3 plus 3 is 6 which is the same as 2
times 3 right so that's one example
another way you can do it is actually
look at the static code so the code
directly so 3 plus 3 in our case even
though it equals 6
is not exactly the same as 2 times 3.
[Music]
likewise some of the issues if we want
to write an apply statement
like this it is not exactly the same as
that
so there's things that we do to make
those two things the same
and also the issue then becomes okay
what about default parameters like narm
equals faults how do we handle that
these two things should be the same but
if we just look at the code it's not
so one way we can then do this if i
believe this was last year's talk and my
our talk
that hadley gave or the year before uh
he introduced a package called lobster
and in the lobster package you can look
at the appstack
abstract syntax tree of any r expression
so code is data so
we can run any piece of our code run it
through the ast function
and it'll come out as a visual tree of
what the code does
so in this example we can see log the
first input of log is the exponentiation
function
and the and the input of that is number
three so if we change
log x exp to 2 we now see log calls exp
calls 2. and for more complicated things
we can see
log calls log inside that version of log
there's a
input of 2 and base equals 10. and so
we essentially use this as a mechanism
to check our code
so that's where grade this comes in it's
an auto-grading system that can be used
with learn or greater exercises
to check the answer but also checking
the code using the abstract syntax tree
so in uh one of the things
is each exercise is independent um
i think there are ways now that they're
working to expand on that
but the initial conception was just to
make life easier
none of the every new exercise has a
clean environment
so that makes it somewhat easier for
finding out bugs but it makes it harder
to build up on
an existing example but the nice thing
about grade this is it actually gives
tries to give formative feedback not
just saying that the answer is wrong
but it'll try to tell you why and
why do we call this grade this instead
of grade r
uh mainly because during the first week
in my internship someone from uva
actually pushed
a package called grade r2 cran so we had
to go through
an entire system of like what do we name
this thing so now let's create this
named after test this and that's that
naming convention
uh just as a side note my favorite uh
suggestion was one that was called
uh greytron uh as a thing off of
scantrons but that was
a little bit too much so so what does
grade this do
um it tries to give formative feedback
and so down here for example
if i if this at the question asks to
take the square root of the log of the
number two and a student just puts two
instead of just saying that the answer
is wrong uh creating this sentence
i expected of call to square root where
you wrote two try again next time's a
charm
creating that sentence is actually very
difficult
and so the whole benefit
is to use grade this with learnr to give
you a system to grade
these code chunks so there are three
components there's first the base trunk
which is essentially what the student
sees when they first see the exercise so
that can be
empty or pre-filled with blanks or you
know some existing code and they just
need to add the last couple of lines etc
then they need a set of checking chunks
so depending on how you want to check
your code
whether you use just the result there is
a grade result function
whether you want to look at the ast
there is a great code function
and if you are trying to grade like a
function there's a great conditions
which essentially will do like a unit
test system
and you can also add these hint chunks
to have hints in the exercise
so what does uh this look like on the
learner perspective
first thing we need to do is load up the
grade this library and then actually say
that we are using an exercise checker
that's coming from grade this called the
grade learn r function
and this is essentially the hook if you
want to write your own uh grading
function for learnr
and then we have exercise equals true
there is a chunk label
and then this is what the student sees
when they first see the question which
is log
with two blanks and then
if for example we want the student to
enter log of exp
of three we have some mechanism to grade
this
so we can grade this in two ways using
grade result
so the way grade result works is
remember i have these hint
chunks but the check chunk we put in the
grade result function
and then there's a series of passive and
fail if
conditions that grade result takes and
if we're just looking at the result we
can say
hey if the result is equal to 3 then
pass
if the result is equal to 4 fail but
then give this custom
message or if the result
is just 2 actually put in
uh this other result and these are three
different ways that you can specify the
passive fail if
um if you've noticed this function curly
bracket
and this tilde notation if you use the
per r package it is exactly the same
mechanism
uh there you can then also use
gradethis to grade the code so the
difference here is
we also now have to provide a solution
block because it's
checking the solution so the instructor
will put in the solution that they want
to check
and then in the check block they run
grade code
and then there's a mechanism to grade
the conditions so if you're trying to
actually
mark a function you can pass in a suite
of unit tests
and then it'll try to tell you how many
of those tests passed or failed
so in here you would notice that the
chunk names actually matter
this chunk label is actually what ties
the hints
and solution and check code all into one
exercise
um and also as a factor because of
knitter
all of these chunky labels need to be
unique
so to make life a little bit easier one
of the things that i also worked on last
year
was adding a r studio add-on that
essentially throws in this block with a
random sequence
uh for the chunk label just so you can
very quickly create these exercises
without coming up with a new name
because when i work in knitter i almost
never create chunk labels unless i
actually need to so
one of the things that i learned last
year
is being careful with the double equals
operator
you can call it inconsistency or the
documentation is not clear or straight
up bug
but this was one of the things that i
discovered just trying to
trying to actually grade some of the
code um that
i was using for an example and you can
see here here's two
pieces of code i'm using quote so r is
not going to actually execute this
uh command so it's not going to actually
call f of
this but the two things you'll need to
notice is that these two statements
that are going to be compared there is a
difference the last
parameter or the last number or value
passed into this function is actually
different
but if we say is u double equals s
you actually get true um but
that that's a roundabout way of saying
that if you actually want to compare if
two things are actually
equal you use the identical function and
this is one of those
being a user of r versus being a
developer of r
you have to use more robust uh functions
when you are
trying to develop packages
uh we wrote about this essentially the
takeaway is
uh the way quote works if a expression
if what
the way quote works is it will take an
expression
and if it's longer than 60 characters it
will create a vector
60 character in 60 character chunks but
when you use double equals on an
expression and only compares the first
value so that's why it comes out to be
true and
the everything at the end will be
ignored
so learn r versus great this if you're
trying to work with this just this is
the one thing to keep in mind
learn r is is responsible for expression
capturing
uh data reporting uh if you need to
capture how many correct answers a
student got
how much time all of that stuff is
captured in the learn r system
and you essentially have to use that
system to build out
uh like something that you would use for
like a mooc for example or to grade your
own classwork
great this is just responsible for
checking the solution
and reporting back some kind of
statement
whether whether that is just a simple
you got this right or wrong or actually
that
difficult statement of where you got
your
answer wrong
so learn r is actually a very
complicated piece of software
um you essentially need to know all
about how knitter works our markdown
works and how shiny works
it is essentially a big capstone project
one of the current
our studio interns this summer um
nistral
he actually wrote a blog post on
learning how they learn our system works
so if you want to learn more about
all of these tools uh that's a pretty
good blog post to start and he's
definitely
i spent most of my summer just
understanding how uh capturing
expressions work
and so he's actually learning about this
this insane project
all of the exercise components are
passed into the exercise checker
so this exercise checker we in
grade this provide a grade learn our
function but if you
need to do something else this is where
you would put in your own gradar
function or grading function
and everything from learn r like those
parts in the code chunks that all gets
passed
passed into this exercise checker
function so your exercise tracker
function needs to be able to take in
those components
and then you can do whatever you want
with it
how do we deal with pipes so in grade
this we actually go through the
process of unpiping any code that is
piped
so if you do something like df pipe into
dr select column one
the first thing that we do is we detect
if you use pipes and then unpipe all the
code before we do the ast checking
so that's that's why some of these
statements
seem to be um a little
wonky uh when you read them so uh
one other thing you can do is you can
actually use grade this as a standalone
code checker
so for example we can library the grade
this library
let's say the student passed in the
value of five we can actually call grade
result directly
and say if they got the value of five
pass
and here's the magic sauce is that there
is actually an argument called learn our
args
it takes a value called last value and
then this is what it's being used
internally to check
uh the student result
and then you get a a graded object back
a greater graded object back which is
really just a list
uh with a message and whether or not the
answer was correct
you can also use this to gray code so we
can quote uh arbitrary expressions i'm
going to set it to student code and
solution code
and then you can also call the graycode
function directly
and then the magic sauce here is there
is a greater arts parameter which takes
a list
and takes in those two expressions and
then you get the same greater graded
object back which is just a message and
whether or not it is correct
one of the things i learned during the
internship is actually how tidy eval
works so in about two minutes i'm going
to explain to you how this works
uh we've seen formulas in ggplot and
writing our
formulas for models and we can say tilde
x
carat two and we can actually save this
to a variable
it is a formula and has that expression
and what we can actually do is take the
second argument
of formula and it gives in the actual
quoted expression
and that's sort of that's and we can do
that with anything with the tilde and
that's how the tilde
works um and then from tidy eval we can
say
what is the expression so this x carat
two and the magic sauce here
is we can pass in a data parameter
defining
what all of those variables in the
expression mean so we can say
in that expression we're going to set x
equals to five
if we want we can also provide a an
environment if it's not provided in data
and then when we eval this expression
it calculates it and so in actual
practice
that little bit of code is actually what
we use and grade this
and so what i just showed you is exactly
that same mechanic
um and so this is an art conference but
uh nistral is actually working on the
python port upgrade this
and so you will be able to do code
checking in python
uh right now you can actually still use
the uh result checking in python because
of reticulate and how articulate works
but we are slowly working on uh
implementing this from the python world
and so with that i would say thank you
for my talk uh coming to this talk and
you can find me here
and uh the slides are there and right
after this i will be posting the slides
as the pdf
so thanks thank you dan
so now we come to our lunch break we are
miraculously
ahead of schedule this has never
happened in the past five years
of the seven different conferences we've
run we've never been ahead of schedule
we actually thought the digital
conference would be further behind than
the real
person one this is amazing so we're
going to get back on schedule by taking
a slightly longer lunch break